today on the matt welsh show our culture
has turned womanhood into a costume for
men to wear we'll discuss the latest
example it's pretty ridiculous example
also colin powell died of covid and the
media are quick to point out that he had
comorbidities but why is this the one
time that they actually want to talk
about covet
and the loudoun county prosecutor
defends his decision to send a rapist
student to another school where he
proceeded to rape again his defense is
not very convincing plus outrage over
hooters did you know that they require
their waitresses to wear skimpy outfits
shocking stuff i had no idea in our
daily cancellation we will deal with a
feminist college professor who says that
men have an unfair advantage in the
workplace because of all the bonding we
guys do in the bathroom there are a
number of problems with that theory of
hers and we'll discuss that and so much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know something we all deal with uh
especially as we grow older is fatigue
during the day you know especially when
you get there so i don't know what it is
about two or three o'clock where you
just feel you feel yourself crashing but
you can't sprawl out on the floor and
take a nap in the middle of the office
trust me i've learned the hard way uh
but you also can't just keep drinking
more and more caffeine because that's
not good for you and that's why we are
introducing a new way to start your day
super beets heart chews they're a tasty
treat they give you the energy you need
and they're good for you as well no more
afternoon coffees energy drinks candy
for a quick pick-me-up you can add two
delicious plant-based super beet heart
chews juice to your morning routine and
promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without a caffeine crash because
super beets heart shoes are unique
they're clinically researched and they
just flat out work they give you that
energy and you feel it and there's no
crash later like there is so often with
caffeine do more for your heart and
treat yourself with super beats heart
shoes um you can join over 1 million
customers get free shipping and returns
a 90-day money-back guarantee and right
now you get a free 30-day supply with
your first purchase at superbeats.com
walsh that's superbeats.com walsh so we
begin today with perhaps the most
important news story of our time this is
an urgent controversy one which demands
our full attention the question at issue
is this who was the first man to wear a
dress was it billy porter or harry
styles that's what we find ourselves
debating today
uh and i think for good reason you know
i can't imagine any subject more salient
more paramount than this you may
remember about a year ago
when the uh pop star harry styles
appeared on the cover of vogue dressed
like a nine-year-old girl who just
raided her grandmother's closet and this
was we were informed at the time a
historic moment i mean a man in a dress
what courage what innovation
previous generations won world wars and
they invented space travel
we put our male pop stars in dresses
that is our contribution to the
historical conversation and what a
contribution it is
when all when you know when it was all
said and done of course
most of us thought that the story was
over harry styles had worn a dress
peace and harmony had been established
across the globe mankind had reached its
zenith
utopia was upon us
or so we thought
little did we know that things were far
more complicated there was a darker side
to harry's blouse
there were skeletons in the closet or
perhaps out of the closet in this case
as has been reported uh this morning by
cnn buzzfeed yahoo news
the daily beast los angeles times tmz
many of our nation's other most uh
prestigious publications
billy porter has emerged all these
months later
to talk about the pain and trauma that
harry styles skirts have caused him
now porter is an actor i think honestly
i'm not exactly sure what he actually
does for a living or why anybody knows
his name as far as i can tell his
primary occupation is to dress in tacky
pant suits
and attend award shows somehow he's
found a way to monetize that hobby of
his more power to him i suppose and he's
not happy that harry styles is stealing
his his um cross-dressing
drag queen thunder from the cnn report
it says in an interview with british
paper the sunday times porter argued
that there was a disconnect and the
opportunities afforded to him as a black
gay man and those given to styles quote
i feel like the fashion industry has
accepted me because they have to he said
i created the conversation about
non-binary fashion and yet vogue still
puts harry styles a straight white man
in a dress on the cover for their for
their first uh for the first time
i was the first one doing it and now
everybody's doing it i'm not dragging
harry styles but he doesn't care he's
just doing it because it's the thing to
do
this is politics for me this is my life
i had to fight my entire life to get to
the place where i could wear a dress to
the oscars
all styles has to do is be white and
straight
then he later on went on to say i
changed the whole game i personally
changed the whole game and that's not
ego that's just a fact
this is he's fought his whole life
this is the this is this is it this is
the achievement of his life
is to wear a dress to the oscars
and it's not ego you know uh he wants to
be sure that we understand not at all
why would we think that a man who cries
to the media because he doesn't get to
be the only guy wearing a dress has an
ego
billy porter's a humble man i mean he's
a man of dignity
a man of humility
prancing on the red carpet in a ball
gown
yeah he's prancing but he's doing it in
a dignified way
but is it true that he invented the
concept of cross-dressing well no of
course it's not not remotely this is one
of the many contradictions we run into
with the proponents of gender fluidity
on one hand they insist that you know
nothing they're doing is novel or
unprecedented they assure us that all of
their wildest gender inventions have a
long and storied history
they say that there were you know
trisexual genderqueer sadomasochistic
furries back in george washington's time
maybe he was one himself who knows
traditional cultures throughout the
globe have expansive ideas about gender
they tell us you could hack your way
into the amazon rainforest and stumble
across an uncon uncontacted tribe and no
doubt that tribe will have its own sex
reassignment clinics
this is all quite widespread it's
universal it's in keeping with
historical precedent they say but then
on the other hand
when a man puts on a miniskirt and winks
at a camera
they want us to throw him a parade as if
he just landed on the moon
so all of this stuff is normal and
universal and totally ordinary
and also revolutionary and bold and
unique and daring all at once well okay
then
and yet
there's something revealing i think
about this controversy if we can call it
that
because we notice again in perhaps you
know the most direct and explicit way
that we've seen yet
how womanhood has been turned into a
trophy to be one
or a flag to be captured
billy porter
other guys like him they wear femininity
like a halloween costume
it looks ridiculous on him it looks ugly
profane vulgar
he appropriates it he makes a mockery of
it and he demands to be celebrated
now sure anybody can wear a dress that's
precisely why it's no achievement to
wear one
but dresses are designed to accentuate
the female form
if you have no female form to accentuate
at best you'll end up looking silly like
a dog and a sweater worse because you're
ridiculing uh and you look worse than
that because you are ridiculing the
feminine
even while trying to claim it as your
own
you have turned womanhood into a
performance
into a comedy
a not very funny one
more of a farce a tragedy
but there are still more direct ways of
going about that of course
like rachel levine who's the biological
male hhs official who according to an
announcement for the bible
administration this morning
has now been sworn in as a four-star
admiral admiral making him the u.s
public health services quote first ever
female four-star admiral
that's the official announcement for the
administration that's in there that's in
their press release
first ever female four-star admiral is a
man
female not even saying woman but female
he's been given not just the social
designation but the biological one as
well
womanhood was awarded to him
like the four-star rank
it's a badge that he can wear around on
his chest
like his fake breasts it's just a it's a
it's a fake thing that he can wear
around it's an object
that's what these people have made of
womanhood
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as someone who as i've told you
many times who struggles with
nausea
uh nausea just when i turn on the news
and see what's happening in the world
but but also when i when i uh especially
when i'm driving or not right when i'm
driving but i'm in the back of a car
that's what it really hits me is if i'm
in the passenger in the back of a car at
an uber or something that's when the
nausea hits me and that's why
i've gone through different solutions in
my life until i stumbled upon relief
band relief ben is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that's
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is 100 drug free
it's non-drowsy and it provides all
natural relief with zero side effect
effects for as long as needed this is
the solution to your troubles uh relief
ban is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that's been used in
hospitals and ecology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting
and if you know somebody who deals with
nausea relief band makes a great gift as
well as the world's opening back up
don't let the fear of nausea keep you on
the sidelines right now relief ban has
an exclusive offer just for my listeners
if you go to reliefband.com use promo
code walsh you'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping any no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20 off all right so
um quick quick uh the psa if i if i may
as we're once again on the road here
as our
world tour continues
and
a note to uh uh
pilots if i could on planes
you know there's this thing there's a
concept of tmi too much information
and i think if you're in far be it for
me to give you any advice whatsoever
uh but
this is a mistake that pilots make
sometimes
where they they and i guess they figure
you know we're sitting back there we
want to know everything that's going on
we don't at least i'll speak for myself
i don't want to know i don't want to
know what's happening up there i just
want you to get us there i don't even
like to see when the door cracks open
and i see
the cockpit and i see all the buttons
and the levers and everything
and it just looks like for it looks to
me like 600 opportunities for things to
go terribly wrong so i don't like to
know i don't like to see but sometimes
the captains you know they'll come on
the intercom and they'll give
information so we were about to take off
on our flight yesterday to head here and
uh the pilot comes on the intercom and
he says
he says he apologizes for the delay
which is all he needed to do because
there was a delay just oh you know we're
working something out it's a delay but
instead he tells us that uh they're
having a problem with one of the engines
and he said it's no big deal but it
doesn't start like normal and so it has
to be manually started no big deal it's
just a it's a problem with the engine
we're about to be 35 000 feet in the air
going 500 miles an hour uh and we have a
faulty engine no big deal
and it probably is no big deal but you
know i'm ignorant i don't know anything
about any of this none of us do
so as far as we're concerned it's
basically pixie dust that keeps us up in
the sky it's magic
we're flying on the the wings of angels
basically and so if you give us
a little bit of information
and we don't have the rest to fill in
the context
then all we're left with is our
imagination and that's the problem so
unless you're going to give us a full on
lesson in aerodynamics to explain to us
why the faulty engine isn't a big deal
then don't tell us anything because then
i'm thinking you need you need to
manually
start it from outside of the plane as we
said so so what happens if the engine
goes out in the air
and it needs to be manually restarted
from outside is someone crawling out on
the wing is that one of the jobs of the
person in the exit road is that
i've always wondered when they tell you
in the exit row and they come up and
they say oh you're in the exit row here
you know you have to be ready to help us
and nobody ever asks what exactly are we
doing for you in case things go wrong
maybe this is one of them
you're closest to the extra rope pop
that thing open climb out there get the
engine started
uh anyway
and then they also told us before we got
on the flight the uh the woman at the
the gate said that we should be happy
and uh we should you know say say hello
to the captain on the way in because
he's a he's a really good pilot he's one
of the best
and then that made me think
well this is the first time i've been
specifically told about a really good
pilot what about all the other flights
i'm on are those the bad ones
all right
uh we'll we'll start here this is from
breitbart it says president joe biden
expressed his regret monday that former
secretary of state colin powell died of
complications from the coronavirus
despite being fully vaccinated
biden commented on powell's death after
a surprise appearance at the white house
honoring the state and national
teachers of the year on monday
and here's what he told reporters he
said by the way he had serious
underlying conditions as you know that's
the problem
it wasn't that the vaccinations aren't
good he had two very serious underlying
conditions and unfortunately didn't work
god love him
unfortunately didn't work
the vaccine didn't work it sounds like
what he said
so this is this interesting thing is
happening now
where
um president biden
the democrats the media
you know i say these as if they're all
mutually exclusive groups which they
aren't
but they're very quick to tell us that
colin powell he was i think 84 years old
he had multiple comorbidities you know
he had
multiple serious illnesses 84 years old
he gets coveted he's been fully
vaccinated he dies
and they're very quick to tell us about
the comorbidities and hey by the way
he's he was very very old and he was and
he was sick and um
and you know his time was was was coming
very soon unfortunately anyway and and
so
it's it's it's not that the vaccines
didn't work
this is the one time
i can't think of any other time this is
the one time when they've when they have
made a point to focus on co-morbidities
on the fact that someone's older
one time they do it
in fact it this a total role reversal
because
tucker carlson was talking about
uh colin powell's death on his show
yesterday and he mentions how he was
fully vaccinated and he got covered he
died and that's true
and this morning
the media is blasting tucker carlson
for not
making a a point to highlight the
comorbidities
when usually they're the ones who aren't
highlighting that fact
why are they doing it well obviously
because they're trying to defend the
dignity and honor of the vaccine
that this that's why this is the one
time
uh when the comorbidities actually
matter
if it wasn't for that
if he was not fully vaccinated
and he died with covid at the age of 84
and along alongside a bunch of other uh
terminal illnesses
they wouldn't be mentioning those
illnesses at all we know that
all right next we've got from the daily
wire it says as we continue to track the
situation in loudoun county
loudoun county prosecutor buddha
defended the decision to transfer a boy
accused of sexually assaulting a female
student in a girl's bathroom to a
different high school in the same school
district late last week telling local
media that the boy had no prior record
the daily wire reported earlier in
october that scott smith's daughter was
allegedly raped in a high school
bathroom by a male student who
reportedly identifies as gender fluid
so we know about the background there
then the 15 year old student who was
according to smith charged with several
counts of sexual assault
including a charge of forcible rape and
a charge of forcible sodomy ostensibly
violent crimes the student however was
transferred to another school
within the same district and reportedly
went on to commit a second sexual
assault
bibiraj according to smith and smith's
attorney elizabeth lancaster pushed for
jail time against smith who was slapped
with charges of disorderly conduct and
resisting arrest
and
bibaraj
of course knew
when smith showed up to the to the
school board meeting and was extremely
extremely angry because his daughter had
just been raped in a bathroom
um
and then gets arrested bibaraj knew
exactly all of the background on it
he's the prosecutor
and yet he's still pushed for jail time
for this father
think about how evil and twisted that is
and just cruel and callous
you know that this is the father of a of
a young girl who's been raped
in a school in your district
and he commits the crime of getting
upset
at a school board meeting
upset after
they just lied to his face
and said that no rape occurred
and you want to throw them in jail for
that
just complete and total callousness and
cruelty on the part of these people
um
bibaraj told the washington dc news
outlet quote we believed based on the
facts
that he had no history of having done
this prior to this offense that was
alleged
she said because of that there was a
belief it was unlikely
he would reoffend she said her office
consulted with the family of the victim
and the office of probation about the
decision she said the judge agreed with
the recommendation
she then suggested that there are
unreported details about the alleged
attack
i would ask this for people to be
patient because as we know what
sometimes is reported initially is not
then what the end result of all the
facts are
so
her excuse
for sending this um alleged rapist to
another school where he allegedly raped
again is that he had no prior history of
committing rape except for the one he
just committed
so what she's saying is
yeah except for that
except for that he hadn't raped anybody
and so that's why we sent him to another
school
again cruelty and callousness
total disregard for
the safety of
of of the kids in the school
not at all concerned about what is
actually the right thing to do that that
doesn't even factor in
related issue here terry mcauliffe as we
head to the gubernatorial election
in early november in virginia
now we know that terry mccullough has
gotten himself into trouble
because he said during a debate that
that parents should not be the ones
deciding
what their their their own kids are
taught in school that's what he said
those were his own words
and uh he's he it was a mistake to say
that out loud
that's that's one of those things that
uh you shouldn't think at all but if you
do you shouldn't say it out loud when
you're running for governor of virginia
and so this has been a this has been a a
real crisis for him heading into the
election and to to show you how bad it
is
here is an ad that the terry mcauliffe
campaign just put out as we're just two
weeks away from the election and this is
their kind of closing argument listen to
this
as parents dorothy and i have always
been involved in our kids education we
know good schools depend on involved
parents that's why i want you to hear
this from me
glenn youncan's taking my words out of
context i've always valued the concerns
of parents it's why as governor we
scaled back standardized testing
expanded pre-k and invested a billion
dollars in public schools i'm terry
mccall candidate for governor and i
sponsored this ad because working
together we can give our kids the
education they deserve yeah that is
never a good sign when you're running a
campaign and you have to put out an ad
that contains the words i've been taken
out of context
that is never a good sign especially two
weeks from the election and it's not
true of course he's not being taken out
of context that's exactly what he said
parents should not be the one
the ones to decide what their kids are
taught that's what he said
you know that that's the quote from his
own mouth we all heard him say it
no when he says taken out of context
what he means is i didn't mean to say
that out loud
that's not the same thing as being taken
out of context
but never a good sign when when this is
your closing argument that oh i've been
taken out of context
that means of course that you're you're
on defense
that this this is almost at the level of
not quite but uh who was that republican
in delaware years ago who put out the ad
i think running for senate put out an ad
saying i'm not a witch
she had to defend herself from charges
of being a witch and uh you know this is
not quite quite as bad as that but uh
it's still it's still pretty bad
all right so here are two people that
we're going to lump together seemingly
unrelated stacey abrams and pete budage
first there's a documentary about pete
buttage coming out
for some reason and there's a trailer
and for some reason i'm going to play
that trailer for you now here it is
watch it
anything you want to make sure that i
ask him
you spent so much of your life hiding
who you truly were
did you feel like you were able to be
your true self on the campaign trail
[Music]
a hometown boy who went to harvard and
became a rhodes scholar only to return
to the city where he grew up he's also a
newlywed i made pete promise that we
would have fun
this is the only chance you'll ever get
to vote for a maltese american
left-handed episcopalian gay war veteran
may or may not
it's a leap going from being a mayor to
being a presidential candidate
but i realized i had something to offer
that was just different
i i mean there are literally
literally dozens
of people who will be waiting to watch
that documentary
that's probably that's probably a
generous estimate now uh i'll have
something to say about that in a minute
but like i said i'm going to put these
together we also have stacey abrams she
was campaigning in virginia for terry
mcauliffe and he's brought in
stacey abrams he's brought in camille
harris he's got you know joe biden
helping him out so he's bringing in all
these people from outside
for this gubernatorial race all these
people who are not who are not residents
of virginia
and he's bringing them in to help him
out
but but but remember
you know at a school board meeting they
don't want outsiders
if you're if you're not from virginia if
you're not a resident or at least a
former former resident like me then you
don't belong there
and they say that while their
their gubernatorial candidate
is enlisting
it's pretty much nothing but people from
outside of virginia what does that tell
you
so here's stacey abrams campaigning in
virginia for terry mcauliffe and here's
what she had to say
you see i'm here to tell you that just
because you win doesn't mean you're one
we've got folks who are ready to take
back what they think is theirs but they
are not entitled to our progress
they are not entitled to our justice
they are not entitled to our votes
but either we use them or we lose them
i come from a state where i was not
entitled to become the governor
but as an american citizen and a citizen
of georgia i'm going to fight for every
person who has the right to vote to be
able to cast that vote and here in
virginia you need to cast that vote for
terry mcauliffe
you need to cast that vote for holla
ayala
you need to cast that vote for mark
harry
and while you're at it go all the way
down the ballot don't stop till you
reach the bottom
and then double check your work
[Applause]
because we know
blow vu all the way through
because we know what is possible okay
first of all uh you're you're actually
correct stacey abrams that you're not
entitled to become governor
she says that like it's a bad thing i
wasn't entitled to be governor well yeah
of course you're not entitled to be
governor no one isn't entitled to be
governor
that's exact that's exactly our point
but she still has not accepted the
results of of that election which is
this is an ongoing insurrection
being led by the the militant radical
insurrectionist stacey abrams in the
state of georgia ongoing she has not
accepted those results
she still claims to be basically the
shadow governor of of georgia
but
when you watch that clip you see the
thing with with p buddha judge
these two are similar in that
these are two of the most incredibly
unimpressive
relentlessly unappealing people
in in all of politics
and they're also losers
i mean they're making a documentary
about a guy who was mayor of
south bend i think it was
and then he runs for president and he
and he fails miserably
and then they make him transportation
secretary
and he proceeds to take a two-month paid
vacation
in the middle of a transportation crisis
and he gets a documentary
stacey abrams has just never done
anything
what has she done why is she a thing
she's like billy this is uh this is the
political billy porter
she's a thing we all know her name
nobody knows why she's never done
anything at all
she has no talent no charisma
she looks a little bit better in address
than billy porter but not much
and and
but you see how this is this is what
makes them they're almost impressive in
their unimpressiveness because
they have the most powerful pr team in
the world which is the american media
trying to make these two stacey abrams
and pete buddha judge into rock stars
doing everything they can to make them
into rockstars to make them a thing
and it still isn't taken
i mean if you have that kind of um
pr support and you if you have that sort
of marketing
this is really millions and millions of
dollars of marketing that are behind
them
officially and unofficially
and that should be enough to make almost
anyone at least on camera
seem like a star
you could just pull like any random
person off the street
put put millions of dollars of marketing
behind them
uh put the entire media behind them
and you can make them into a star
and it still has not really worked with
stacey abrams and p p buddhist
that that's what that's what nothings
they are
absolute nothings
for them it's not like you're pulling a
person off the street to try to make
them start this is like trying to pull a
roll of paper towels
off of your kitchen counter and making
that into a rock star
harder job
okay uh
we got to talk about this hooters thing
which is really important but
before we get there one other brief
thing i want to play for you this is uh
jon stewart in an interview had some
thoughts some i thought quite incoherent
thoughts about cancel culture let's
listen to that
people that talk about cancer culture
never seem to shut the [ __ ] up about it
like there's more speech now than ever
before it's not you can't say it's that
when you say it
look the internet has democratized
criticism what do we do for a living
we talk
we criticize
we postulate we opine
we make jokes
and now other people
are having their say
and that's not cancel culture
that's
relentlessness yeah he didn't say it but
he's this he's going with it's not
cancelled culture it's accountability
right that's what he's going with
and
we are we're simply pretending and or at
least jon stewart is pretending he wants
us to pretend um
that
you know
or or rather we're ignoring all of the
cancelled people
who weren't even public figures
weren't even trying to make a statement
i mean think about this there are so
many examples you couldn't possibly list
them all
one that comes immediately to mind is uh
what about that you know the truck
driver
um
who was driving along and and it was
like cracking his knuckles
and made the mistake of of
when when he was cracking one of his
fingers to
make the okay gesture incidentally
and next thing you know that guy's got
the internet mom coming after me loses
his job he loses everything
is that is that jon stewart is that just
relentlessness
okay that was someone who wasn't trying
to make any statement at all he was just
living his life
and the mob tracked him down and ruined
it for no reason
this is one of the hallmarks of
cancelled culture
no canceled culture is not just
i uh express an opinion and people are
just disagree with that opinion and they
let you know about it
that's not cancelled culture people let
me know every day that they disagree
with my opinions
a cancel culture
is um
one of one of the hallmarks is
when you go they go digging for it
they go looking
okay let's let's find a reason let's dig
up a reason to ruin someone
john gruden
he wasn't out making any public
statements at all to anyone
this is not him being held accountable
for the opinions that he chose to
express
you know something with john gruden
if he had stood up
during a press conference
after a game
and had said some of those things that
he said in the email
and he lost his job for it
i wouldn't be defending him i would say
okay fine
because
you're you're a football coach
your job is to coach football you chose
to stand in front of a microphone
and do that
when the people you work for they have
no interest in that
okay so you you chose to take it this
direction knowing the kind of
environment that we live in um you have
have chosen to bring this kind of heat
on your employer and yeah you're going
to face the consequences for that
football coach just stick to football
but that's not what happened
these were private conversations from a
from uh not only in a private email but
from a private email address not even
like an employer's email address this is
from a gmail account or a yahoo account
or something
um
and they went digging for it to ruin his
life
that's cancel culture
cancel culture is also ideological it's
also political
it's it is uh inconsistent in the people
that it targets
so i mean you could call it whatever you
want okay cancel culture is just the
label that we've come up with for this
social phenomenon
if you don't like cancer culture call it
something else
we go back to just a good old-fashioned
pitchfork mob but but there's no denying
the phenomenon itself
you can deny it all you want people can
see what's right in front of their face
all right so
there's been a controversy over the new
uniforms for hooters waitresses
um
apparently the the weight the the
uniforms are have been judged too skimpy
um
for the waitresses
i guess they
hooters had assigned
new shorts that are not really shorts
but they're more like bikini bottoms
and um
the waitresses are very upset about this
and they were making their tick tocks
and they were posting on instagram and
saying look at what we're being for this
is objectification we're being forced to
wear this
this is not what i signed up for when i
went to work for something called
hooters
and now here's the latest from the new
york post
it says hooter's rump roasted new york
uniform policy has bottomed out
what
hooter's rump roasted new uniform policy
has bottomed out i don't even know what
that means new york post
but that doesn't mean anything just get
get to the point or get to the the
article okay i will it says the company
now says it is reversing its recent
mandate that female servers trade in
their already short shorts for new skin
type bikini cut bottoms
um a hooters america representative
wrote an email to business insider quote
as we continue to listen and update the
the images of the hooters girls we're
clarifying that they have the option to
choose from traditional uniforms or the
new ones
quote they can determine which style of
shorts
best fits their body style and personal
image
the cheeky company's turnaround came
after some of its servers took to social
media to rip the new underwear shorts
employee kristen songer said in a
trending tick tock video oh look a
wedgie
um added songer this is why all the
hooter girl hooters girls are upset
because this is not what i agreed to
wear a year ago when i was hired
still there are some others who um
appear to plan to they're still gonna
wear them um tick tock user jazz
e says i've been making way more money
with the new shorts
okay so songer says this is not what i
uh agreed to wear a year ago well
maybe not
but you agreed to work for
a company called hooters
what did you think that meant
did you
did you think that it was a
a fraternity of owl enthusiasts is that
what you actually thought
did you think you were going to work for
a nature center
a bird sanctuary
uh i i somehow i doubt that
this this is what we find again
as usual with this new um especially
pitiful form of feminism
where there's there's no personal talk
about accountability
it's like women acting like they have no
free will
like there are automatons or something
like that
like you just woke up one day and and
you you you
you woke up in a hooters uniform working
for hooters with the name tag and
everything serving people hot wings
or maybe like you were kidnapped like
the hooters showed up at your house they
sent um
they sent their their their armed goons
to your house and put you in chains and
dragged you
to go work for them if hooters does that
then i totally agree then you know i
oppose i oppose that i oppose all of it
um
but no you you decided hey i'm going to
go work for a place
where the whole attraction is women
wearing skimpy outfits
and i'm going to try to profit off of
that
because i'm going to make more tips
working at hooters than i would at
applebee's
presumably
no no one
no one's going to hooters for the for
the food
we all know why they're going so you you
make that choice
and then add act victimized
because you're being objectified yet it
is
is it degrading is it insulting is it
objectifying
to work at a place called hooters
yeah it absolutely is
i could see why women wouldn't want to
work there i could see why most women
don't
this is why no daughter of mine is ever
going to work for a place called hooters
but that's the decision that you made
to go and work there and to objectify
yourself
and here's the thing
when you make that decision
now
you could make that poor decision and
then change your mind and leave that's a
great idea you could say actually i
don't want to do this this is incredibly
insulting
maybe i will go work for applebee's
which is only which is only
slightly less insulting
um you can you know you can make that
decision
but if you choose to stay there in this
objectifying
environment where you where you have
made yourself and your sort of your
sexuality your body into a commodity
when you do that you can't really start
drawing lines in the sand you can try
but you've already bought in
to making yourself into a commodity
so when you say i'm going to sacrifice
i want to sacrifice my dignity but um
but but this little shred of it i wanna
i wanna hold on to
i'll give you my dignity but there's
this this little thimble full of dignity
that i wanna keep for myself i can't
give you all of it
you can try to do that many people have
tried that but it's it's it never works
because once you agree to it what you
find is that
you give up a little bit of your dignity
you end up giving it all
better option would be to just keep it
for yourself
in the first place that would be my
advice
all right let's get now to reading the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let me see here caleb says dad
of three daughters here matt is 100
correct on paternity leave
my current employer gave me two full
weeks of paid leave for the birth of my
youngest i recognize this is a luxury
that it is a discretion of my employer
my previous employer made me use my own
pto and anything more than a week was
frowned upon
when we had our youngest earlier this
year i did spend most of my two weeks
caring for the older two girls and doing
housework for my wife especially because
the baby refused to bond with me
for a full week
um
yeah that is that's why i said before
paternity leave whatever you want to
call it
whether you're taking leave or not um or
if you just have a few days like i did
like caleb did
uh if you have older kids as the dad
then
that becomes your primary role you're
taking care of your wife you're taking
care of the older kids
um while your wife recovers and also
is is the one who's doing the lion's
share of caring for the baby
so that's that's that is another one of
the really important roles that a dad
plays
it's just that this is a this is a sort
of a supporting role
and the thing is there's there's
humility
in acknowledging that
and in saying you know when the when the
baby is born
really all through the pregnancy
the baby is born
uh the the mom mom and baby are the
stars of the show right they're they're
the focal point and you as the dad
you're kinda you're doing the grunt work
you're out on you're you're out on the
edges
um
you're
you you're doing what's what's asked of
you to do
and uh you're you're
picking up slack where you can and
playing that kind of supportive
supporting role
and you would think for me for men to
acknowledge that and say look that's my
role after when that that is my role
here
you would think that feminists and women
and
the left you
you'd think that they would embrace that
and say great
but no it's like they they got mad at me
for not pretending that i had a bigger
role that i have a bigger role than i
really do
which is interesting
um
e432 says you can make the argument that
twins are harder but oh wait mr walsh
has twins and knows what it's like yes
dads can help more with twins i nanny
twins
but the four weeks of paternity leave he
got was just too much yeah twins twins
do of course twins make it a lot harder
having twin babies is is very difficult
that was our first what we started with
twins we dove right into the deep end
with it
and it was really hard but the other
thing is also no matter how much
paternity leave you you have
and i think my wife and i we realized
this that
uh because i only had a few days and i
had to get back to work
well
even if you have four weeks even if you
have eight weeks
you're gonna have to figure out how to
do this with at least one of you working
eventually
so even if you buy yourself four weeks
in the end it doesn't really make much
of a difference because you've got a
whole life now okay you've got a
lifetime now of of being a parent of
twins
and at least 18 years of that life are
going to be there's there's going to be
a lot of challenges
so you got to figure it out
one way or another
um
lrt says when are you gonna do a review
of the let's go brandon rap song number
one on itunes
yeah i wanted to play that song okay so
i you i didn't know about it until you
told me about it uh there is a rap song
a let's go brandon rap song
and um i i did want to play it but
there's
i think every second in the song there's
an f-bomb bomb uh it's it's like part of
the part of the beat is the f-bomb and
so i decided not to do that i had some
mercy on our editors and i decided not
to do that so i can't play but you could
go if you wanted to and go track it down
on youtube
um i did listen to it what's my review
of it uh first of all i just want to say
that it's it's great that you know the
rapper in that song is so so supportive
of brandon
it's great that everybody is so
supportive of brandon these days
and um other than that what can i say i
mean the song really spoke to me it's
catchy it has real depth it has soul to
it
i loved it
too early to talk about where it falls
in the list of greatest songs of all
time i think it's definitely the top 50
no question about it
um and uh beyond that it's really in the
conversation also
about the let's go brandon trend in
general
i i did want to say that i actually
think that this is pretty devastating
politically for joe biden
not to make too much of it
but but i mean that
the trend is devastating not the song
specifically though the fact that
they're making songs now
really tells you something
and i tell you why it's devastating
politically
because let's go brandon along with the
more vulgar version of that chant
all of this makes a mockery of biden
right
it makes him into a joke
into a silly sort of contemptible
ridiculous person
and that's the death knell for a
president
or for any politician
if not the death knell it's it's very
hard to come back from that when you
become a ridiculous
punchline
and the left usually has a much easier
job of doing this to republican
presidents partly because they have the
media on their side also because
you know let's face it some of the most
recent republican presidents
um
have made it pretty easy for the left to
make fun of them
but obama
never really became a joke
um the right could never quite get there
with him he was a joke
in many ways but he was never seen that
way
in the popular imagination
even clinton yeah there were a ton of
clinton punch lines but
it wasn't it wasn't like this
where joe biden is just a joke he's this
pitiful
pathetic
ludicrous clown
and there are a lot of things i mean you
can
make a politician you can paint them if
you figure out how you want to brand
them as the opposition
you can brand them as
tyrannical as lawless as corrupt
dishonest you can brand them as
i mean even even incompetent
none of that i mean all of that they can
they can work around
but you brand them a joke you brand them
ridiculous
and that's hard to come back from
and that's kind of what what the let's
go brandon thing represents
uh and i think it's fantastic i think
it's great you know for those of us who
grew up before smartphones and before
before the before the internet it may
seem to younger people like we have no
past at all because you can't you can't
find our past on on the internet uh we
don't have it stored away on the phones
like did we just fall from the sky one
day where we dug up out of the ground or
something like that
no it's just that our past and our
memories they are stored on
antiquated technology like vhs tapes
photo physical photo albums and all the
rest of it
but don't keep them there don't keep
them in that antiquated technology where
they can be destroyed get legacy box
legacy box is your chance to have aging
tapes films and photos digitally
preserved so the ability so you have the
ability to relive your family history
and it's never lost because of a leaky
pipe or summer days that make your attic
hot enough to melt tapes plus this week
legacy box is offering 40 off at legacy
box dot com slash walsh so you can start
future proofing your pass today the
service is very simple you put
everything in the box you send it over
to legacy box they put it onto a you
know dvd they put it onto the cloud a
thumb drive whatever you want to do
visit legacybox.comwalls to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
40 off take advantage of this exclusive
offer today and then use their kit
whenever you want that's legacybox.com
walsh to save 40 off legacy box dot com
welsh well if you've been searching for
a daily morning podcast without an
agenda look no further than the morning
wire which has been topping the apple
and spotify charts since its release
it's the only daily podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe and start listening
right now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five star review if
you like what you hear let's get now to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel a woman named alice
evans who
according to her bio is a lecturer at
king's college london a faculty
associate at harvard and an author who
writes about issues related to gender
equality and the patriarchy that's
probably more information than you ever
needed to know about somebody called
alice evans but you never know what
you'll learn on this show so the reason
we're talking about her today is that
she recently wrote a blog post which she
shared on twitter titled smash the
fraternity and in the post she complains
that men have an advantage in the
corporate world because of the fraternal
bonds formed through
sports banter she says smoke breaks and
in the men's restroom
now if you're a man hearing this already
you're probably confused because
you probably don't take smoke breaks and
you've never held a conversation with
another person in any restroom in your
life
and i'm just as confounded as you but
we'll get back to that in a moment first
let's hear from alice let's let her make
her case
she says quote
male bosses in male-dominated workplaces
consistently fail to recognize and
elevate female talent
rewards and promotions go to those who
put in long hours men can take advantage
of this system because they're
emancipated by women who continue to
shoulder the burden of social
reproduction at home thus the
contemporary system of employment is
predicated on the domestic gender
division of labor entrenching their
first mover advantage the male
nomenclature tends to disregard women's
expertise and resist family-friendly
reforms so if you really want to level
the playing field it's time to smash the
fraternity
by the way
the word fraternity
doesn't just refer to a group of um
drunken hooligans doing keg stands right
fraternity also means friendship bonds
uh mutual support and respect
what feminist alice wants to do is smash
male friendship
she's noticed that men can get along
with each other can develop bonds of
respect and she wants to destroy that
this comes as no surprise of course
feminists have always been driven almost
exclusively by their desire uh their
jealousy of men and their desire to
become men and the thing that constantly
reminds them
of the fact that they aren't men
is that they're unable to bond with men
the same way that men do with each other
which means that those bonds are the
things that they hate the most
that's why you should never marry a
feminist or date a feminist or spend
more than 45 seconds in a room with a
feminist she'll make your life miserable
in many ways ways you can't even imagine
but this will be a big point of
contention she will not want you to have
male friend she will resent your ability
to get along with other men given that
she cannot get along with other men or
other women for that matter or anybody
back to alice she says patriarchy has
persisted for thousands of years
um yada yada et cetera skipping ahead
male bonding is part of the story
building trust and respect
homosocial schmoozing
talking about sports and sharing smoke
breaks
so if you ever talk about sports with
another man uh just so you know you're
engaging in homosocial schmoozing
just never call it that when you're
talking to the other guy hey you want to
do a little homosocial schmoozing
no
um anyway that accounts for over a third
of the gender pay gap at one asian bank
likewise in u.s big oil where women
comprise 38 of entry-level posts but
only 10 percent of executives
now she continues to complain along
these lines listing all of the areas
where men are able to socialize while
excluding women she's especially
concerned with male fraternizing in the
restroom and she includes this cartoon
i'll show you of a woman looking on
dejected as a group of backslapping men
head into the men's room together with a
sign that says corporate boardroom on
the door
alice also shared a message she received
allegedly from a man
going into more detail about all the
gabbing and bonding that we boys do in
the bathroom supposedly here's the
message from a friend that says
with all your thinking about gender and
management i wanted to share this little
anecdote i used to work at a large
organization i happened to work on the
same floor as the organization's vice
president who was also a man sometimes i
run into him in the bathroom and while
we were both using urinals he'd tell me
some new idea he had and often asked me
to take some action on it at some point
to avoid getting new work i started
using bat the bathroom on another floor
but it definitely suggested to me that
with mail managers male employees get
more casual contact and potentially more
assignments with opportunities to
succeed even in something as simple as
running into them in the restroom
okay
let's just get one thing out of the way
up front all right
ladies take it from me
as a man who has been a man almost my
entire life
literally 85 of my life i've been a man
um
and i've used hundreds of restrooms all
across these fruited planes
the situation described here is as
imaginary as alice's friend it does not
happen
you do not need to worry about it
men are not bonding in restrooms we
don't even speak in restrooms unless
it's absolutely necessary which it never
is
we don't rest in restrooms we don't take
baths and bathrooms either for that
matter we are business oriented
in that environment we go in we take
care of our business and we leave we
don't discuss that business with anybody
we don't discuss any other business
while conducting that business
male restrooms are quiet places
except for the sounds of dribbling and
kerplunking which echo through our
chambers otherwise we remain silent and
we we we give each other space
it's an unwritten rule which all men
know
that when confronted with an empty line
of urinals a man must pick one on either
end never one in the middle never one in
the middle
the man who comes in next will pick one
as far from the first man as he can the
next will again maintain that distance
as much as he can you never choose a
urinal directly next to another man
never unless it's an emergency and it
better be a real emergency and you
better be on the verge of your bladder
rupturing and even then
a decent man would allow his bladder to
rupture in a dignified way a dignified
rupture rather than choose to pee six
inches from another guy these are the
rules they're set in stone maybe not
literal stone but in our hearts and our
souls we as men are born with this
knowledge it's our destiny to follow
these guidelines we all know it
this may be more information than you
ladies need but i'm trying to explain
that men's restrooms are not women's
rooms despite the confusion our culture
has on this topic you know that's not
the case alice seems to think that
because women will take a day trip to
their local restroom and hang out there
for 14 hours pampering themselves
talking and doing god knows what that
men must have the same approach we don't
you'll notice that men never go in
groups to the bathroom like women do
you'll never see a man stand up at a
restaurant and say hey i gotta take a
leak hey bill you wanna come with
in fact if bill does also have to go to
the restroom he'll wait for the other
guy to come back and go and leave and
come back before he goes or else he'll
say oh you're going to the bathroom too
well i had to go also you know what i'll
just get in my car and drive to omaha
and use a bathroom there so you go ahead
because men can never be far enough away
from each other in bathrooms that's the
point
now there are some men who violate these
rules the men who treat urinals like
water coolers
not literally
maybe they do actually drink from the
urinal who knows the freaks
but they'll try to spark a small talk
exchange there are men who do this a few
believe it or not there are there are
some men who will will relieve
themselves in a urinal right next to you
even when there are other open ones
available
we normal men always assume those guys
are weirdos and deviants and we judge
them and we hate them
and are justified in feeling that way
they're the exception
the rule is as i have described
now i may be making too much out of this
but i think what we find in this
bathroom issue
is a microcosm a symbol of feminism's
great flaw one of its great flaws anyway
and that is that feminists don't know
the first thing about men
they don't understand us at all they
have no understanding of who men are how
we act why we act the way we are we're
not even that mysterious it's just that
they're that stupid
as far as men having more success in the
corporate world it's certainly not due
to any kind of institutional bias in
favor of men
all of the institutional bias all of it
without a doubt cuts against men
especially white men
but if we have we if we still have
greater success some of that might have
to do with the inherent masculine skill
sets that men tend to possess
i understand this is heresy i mean all
true things are heresy and a culture of
lies but men and women have different
skills and they excel at different
things men generally speaking may tend
to be better suited and more cut out for
some of these jobs
and some of that has to do with
different priorities also for all the
talk about gender pay gaps and
everything the gap if it exists at all
exists because women tend to make
different choices they choose different
career paths they take different routes
in life and that's fine that's good
that's called diversity
one other point
if men are better able to get along
work as a team relate to each other
outside of the restroom i mean
that's not some kind of unfair advantage
it's an advantage yeah but it's not
unfair
we earn that advantage
by being direct with each other
by not taking things too personally
by not getting overly focused on
personal slights not getting involved in
personal feuds and so on
women can tend
a little more towards the dramatic as
evidenced by alice seeing men walking
into the restroom and imagining that
they're hatching some kind of game of
thrones conspiracy while they stand at
the urinals
the slightly more stoic emotionally
removed and coolly practical approach of
a man often works well in business
it can sometimes cause tension and
strain in relationships though and at
home which is why a man needs a woman to
help him become more empathetic more
caring more relational
there's no problem with this dynamic
unless you decide to make it a problem
and alice is the kind of woman who likes
to make problems
but business is about solving problems
not making them
which is why she's a college professor
not a ceo
and it's also why she is today canceled
and we'll leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show as vaccine
mandates hit home police departments
begin firing cops on mass plus the new
york city council removes a statue of
thomas jefferson remember when trump
said they would do it well he was right
that's today on the bench bureau shall
give it a listen